well new at 4 the economic future of las  vegas looks bright latest data shows  nevada is growing five times the  national average as clark county reaches  a population of 2.4 million now that was  announced today at the las vegas global  economic alliance conference called  vista 2022 and the majority of newcomers  to clark county they say are from  california  the best thing that we can do to attract  a new business to come into our  community is make sure that it is a  great place for the businesses that are  already here to operate and sometimes  that gets lost in the mix  all right some of the top reasons for  moving here a lower cost of living  compared to california and lower state  taxes